hast du dir andere frauen angeguckt oder
an sie gedacht seit wir verheiratet sind
stop stop hast du an andere frauen
gedacht seitdem wir verheiratet sind
gedacht sie kommt sollen die leute wir
werden heute zusammen und ein video
anschauen was uns alle sauer machen wird
so viel ist sicher denn wir werden ein
video von einem pärchen sehen das im
besten fall wirklich im allerbesten und
liebs gemeinden fall lost ist wenn nicht
sogar schlimmer ich halte das android
oder kurz leute volltreffer instrumentes
gezockt und wenn ihr vorschläge für neue
action habt dann in die kommentare
reichen damit wir fangen jetzt an mit
dem video
diese frau macht ihrem mann das leben
zur hölle ist eifersüchtig wie sie die
engländerinnen derby wurde ihr mann
steve den sie über das internet kennen
gelernt hat muss ganz schön einstecken
also ja ja nur mal kurz zurück ein gutes
bild von den beiden haben es geht um
dieses pärchen hier der boss eine
engländerin die gad eben schon gesagt
wurde und ihr freund und sie ist haben
wir in england und ich fürchte auch
darüber hinaus dafür bekannt dass sie
eifersüchtig ist also so wie manche
leute dafür bekannt sind dass sie
besonders unterhaltsam sind oder
besonders gut gegen einen ball treten
können ist sie dafür bekannt dass sie
die negative charaktereigenschaften
versucht aufweist
wir haben die beiden schon vor zwei
jahren getroffen und gemerkt doch
unglaublich pizza ist sie tatsächlich im
tatsächlichen im engsten sinne des
wortes leute also ich meine das ist ja
quasi wie gemacht für den gedanken dass
das bizarr ist wenn man sich allein
schon das springt er sofort ins auge
leute das ist der elefant im raum
sprechen wir es an allein die
körperlichen unterschiede zwischen den
beiden sind ja wirklich extrem und die
sind glaube ich es ist umgekehrt zu dem
was man üblicherweise so auf der straße
das kann man der form schon sagen ich
würde es auf mein bauchgefühl heraus
sagen dass im durchschnitt wenn man eine
studie machen würde auf jeden fall
männer eine höhere körper macht also ein
höheres körpergewicht als ihre freundin
habe
hier ist es anders herum um es mal
gelinde auszudrücken und das springt er
schon ins auge hier zeigt seine devise
geratet wir merkten sie dem erneuten
besuch er ist ja noch mehr verfallen
da müssen wir kraft machen leute um sich
einen kommentar also ich weiß es ja
besser leute als leute in videos auf
direkte wegen ihrem aussehen auch dazu
machen das kann herr lang andere
youtuber machen die sich videos
anschauen gewissen stumpfer sind
vielleicht macht versucht das für
gewöhnlich nicht mehr zu machen falls
ich es früher war gehört habe
diese eigene glaube da jetzt wirklich so
geil von lieven alter david guetta ist
ja richtig abgestürzt gut drauf haben
ganz viele gemeinsame interessen
es ist wirklich geisteskrank es wirklich
geistig also wenn dieses video mit hoher
wahrscheinlich erreicht nämlich diese
beziehung dieses pärchen wird alles
dauer macht oder so es ist ja wirklich
also es ist wirklich eigentlich ist es
zum schreien
es ist wirklich zum schreien hätte man
irgendjemanden den auftrag gegeben
bruder entwickelt eine beziehung bringt
zwei menschen zusammen damit bei diesen
beiden menschen die leute dass ich auf
den ersten blick schon denken what the
[ __ ] mann weiß dieses pärchen derby hat
glück so einen verständnisvollen mann
gefunden zu haben
sie leidet an extreme eifersucht derby
rastet sofort raus wenn steve im
fernsehen das ist das kann mir keiner
erzählen auch nicht bei der
eifersüchtigen engländerin der welt dass
sie ihn jetzt dafür an macht dass er
sich in einem prospekt oder in einer
zeitschrift die sich anschaut da ist
eine frau drin die werbung macht für was
weiß ich vitamintabletten
materialistisch wahrscheinlich macht wir
gehen gleich noch näher darauf ein warum
ich denke dass sie sich so verhält wie
sie sich verhält aber wie kann man denn
mit dieser einstellung ins fernsehen
gehen also ich würd mal sagen dass das
schreit zum himmel dass diese frau so
probleme hatten was denkt sie sich ja
auch hier also ich glaube ich habe
irgendwie bisschen probleme in dem
sozialen zusammenleben mit einer
menschlich kann leuten nicht vertrauen
ab mit mir ins nationale und weltweite
fernsehen damit jeder mensch sehen kann
wie schrecklich tropfen derby wurde als
eifersüchtig sste frau englands bekannt
sie glaubt steve können worte obwohl er
sie anbietet perfekt und haben
geheiratet
die mega andere beziehung so schatz ich
vertrau dir einfach
art und weise könnte mein gesamtes
vermögen haben wir leben ein leben ab
jetzt zusammen sie so launig frauen den
fernsehzeitschriften an einfach die
eifersüchtig sste frau englands der
beschließt ihren liebsten deshalb
mehrmals am tag an einen lügendetektor
und zu brüchen nicht vielleicht doch auf
dumme gedanken kommt diese dinge auch
mal falsch leuchten können
ganz im ernst leute wenn sie schon ein
bisschen fernsehen geschaut hat von
internet geschaut hat wir können ihn
nicht erzählen dass das echte menschen
sind das könnt ihr mir nicht erzählt
soll ich nicht weil ich weigere mich zu
akzeptieren dass solche menschen auf der
welt existieren dieses pärchen sieht
wirklich einfach so aus als hätte man es
einfach erfunden als wenn das
schauspieler- und hätte den gesagt
verhaltet euch so und so damit man am
besten einen fernsehbeitrag darüber
machen kann die los die sind aber ganz
ehrlich denen dir diesen lügendetektor
hast du auf wunsch bestärkt
wenn überhaupt das ist doch wirklich so
ein scheiß fünf euro teil und davon
machst du jetzt eine beziehung abhängig
und das emotionale wohlbefinden von
einem anderen menschen
was hast du gemacht bruder was hat was
hast du gemacht das früher so ich würde
sagen halt der welt halt früher gute
musik gemacht kann man jetzt nicht
wirklich sagen aber muss sagen von vor
10.000 bis 100.000 menschen auf festival
spielen zu derby heiraten
es war alles okay mit mir bis zum
letzten moment als ich dann wirklich vor
dem standesbeamten stadt ja glaube ich
in dem moment hast du glaub ich gemerkt
das ist ja ich dachte will das alles nur
eine mini damit leute uns irgendwie
kennen und wie wir im fernsehen sind
irgendwie aufträge bekommen das wird
aber dann
bereits zu spät dabei hatte keine
zweifel die heirat war wirklich ein
das beweist ein bisschen dreist
gesprochen so in diesem in diesem
beitrag oder dann gab es keinen weg mehr
zurück mehr
dann war er in der falle also leute
lebens jetzt auch bisschen also fenster
muss ich zugeben aber der hat zwei
menschen geheiratet so und rtl2 tut so
als wäre jemand mit seinem fuß in eine
bärenfalle rein gedreht man kommt da
nicht mehr raus
ja ja ich kann sich genau benennen was
genau es ist es auf jeden fall nicht nur
sein äußeres erscheinungsbild und sein
aussehen aber er macht in meinen augen
nicht den eindruck dass er eine person
ist die entwickelt genug ist um das
auszugleichen
diese krankhafte eifersucht die ja ich
würde mal sagen einfach aus einem
schlechten selbstwertgefühl kommt ja
darauf so ich hab das gefühl ich bin
nicht gut genug für die andere person
deswegen muss ich die kontrollieren
damit sie mir nicht wegläuft also er
macht nicht den eindruck als könnte er
das ausgleichen und jemand der gesund im
kopf ist hatte keinen bock auf so was
also keine ahnung
steve pflegt sie jetzt vollzeit und
macht alles für sie
zur belohnung dafür ab und zu alleine
fernsehen schauen während der b im bett
lebt oder stundenlang auf ihre xbox
spielt halt wir uns noch vor allem was
wir gerade gehört haben leute er pflegt
sie ja was ich davor übersprungen habe
ist deswegen ihrem übergewicht nicht
arbeitsfähig deswegen pflegt ihr mann
sie macht diesen neues haus gezogen
macht die ganze arbeit im haus und zur
belohnung hat er manchmal manchmal seine
ruhe
menschenrechte sind ziemlich abstoßend
der friede wird aber auch wenn nur der
kleinste verdacht besteht vor steve
etwas haben straßen nrw nicht gefällt
bongo bongo als eiskalte hat er sich
gerade eben einfach einfach ein musik
video angeschaut wurde frau drin
vorkommt oder kommst du noch klar ich
glaube du spinnst absolutes no go ahead
sie betrogen leute es ist offiziell hat
sie betrogen jetzt muss sie sich
scheiden lassen
bitte an dieser stelle einwendungen von
psycho andreas wir die tür zur haut weil
ich das jetzt nicht mehr selbst machen
mit meinen nachbarn diese frage hast du
an andere frauen
das hat sie jetzt nicht wirklich gesagt
heute hast du an andere frauen gedacht
seitdem wir verheiratet sind gedacht
deutschland eine sache doch leute was
machen sie hat nicht nur den ruhig
lügendetektor sondern sie hat da noch
eine app auf dem smartphone um seine
lügen zu überprüfen also dass niemand
kann mir erzählen dass das ist eine
echte beziehung ist da hat sich
irgendeine ausgedacht fürs fernsehen und
die tun jetzt so als ob das kann nicht
sein
[Musik]
also ich bin da ganz ehrlich mit euch
leute ich glaube dass man die menschheit
gerade dadurch dass das es so viele
menschen auf der welt gewinnt
deutschland gibt engern geburt er war zu
extremer dummheit im einzelfall face und
das ist einzel menschen gibt menschen
gibt die wirklich geisteskrank hängen
geblieben sind aber das hier kann ich
mir beim besten leben nicht vorstellen
ich glaube ich glaube ich komme ich
glaube dass es nicht echt oder nicht
eins zu eins so wie es hier dargestellt
wird den kommentaren ob ihr denkt dass
das echt ist oder nicht oder ob das fürs
fernsehen gestellt
es kann nicht die wahrheit seien leute
jack dietrich vorgeschlagen das video ab
abonniert war ich bin an der strauß
bleibt stabil und denkt nicht an andere
frauen und männer werden beziehungsweise
weil das fremdgehen
ich spüre wie es mir langsam hoch kommen